[Music]
lady gaga and ariana grande
took the vmas by storm with a
show-stopping performance of their hit
collab
rain on me their performance was
arguably one of the most anticipated of
the night
i am so excited to see ariana and gaga
i am most excited to see lady gaga and
ariana grande perform
i'm obsessed with them this year i'm
definitely the most excited to see
ariana grande in lady gaga right now
he's one of my favorite songs
the two won the best collaboration award
which kicked off
gaga's winning streak
[Music]
the 34 year old took home five awards
including
artist of the year best song and the
show's
first ever tricon award which recognizes
artists who have become superstars in
multiple fields
such as music acting and philanthropy
i also hope that people at home that
have big dreams
i hope they see me here today and
accepting this award and know
how grateful i am and i want you to know
that you can do this too
during her performance gaza brought her
new album chromatica
to life with a number of costume and set
changes
including a brain piano during the
ceremony the singer asked fans to mask
up
and with each of her nine outfits she
led by example gaga kicked things off on
the red carpet with this look
an astronaut inspired helmet and
metallic dress
she shared this photo on instagram
captioning it quote
i was wearing face shields before it was
a thing
hashtag vmas this year mother monster
gave fans some insight
into how she prepared for her
performance by sharing a photo of her
taking an
ice bath captioning it hashtag vmas
i love you thank you mtv thank you fans
i love you the best